we got cnn uh good old trusty cnn
facebook tried to punt the trump
decision that backfired it's an
interesting take
they say the facebook oversight board
was designed to make some of facebook's
most difficult
decisions for the company but on
wednesday the board put one of the
biggest dilemmas facing the platform
back on facebook and company ceo mark
zuckerberg
the board said facebook was right to
suspend trump in the immediate aftermath
of the insurrection but facebook
couldn't just
make the suspension indefinite with no
actual rule on its book
so basically everybody was waiting for
this huge moment
was this supposedly independent body
going to say donald trump should be
allowed back on instead they were like
well i mean
mark mark you decide so there's no real
point having them we knew this is going
to be the case
we know that let me just slow down
is anyone really surprised i'm surprised
people are like
well this is crazy a sitting president
was banned he was banned
four months ago what are you talking
about how's this news yeah i mean did
anyone really expect this
facebook oversight board staffed
entirely by anti-trump figures
uh people who compared trump to hitler
in one case was ever going to come to
any other conclusion of course they're
going to uphold the ban and what they've
done is they've essentially passed the
buck back to facebook saying you know
well in in six months you have to make a
final decision it's in your court now
so uh facebook already made their final
decision yeah the oversight board was
supposed to be the special thing but i'm
i just love how how stupid so many
people are
when they were like first of all the
journalists who were like oh no
oh what what if what if they overturned
trump's ban oh geez
but then you have these these gop guys
these these uh congressmen and women
who are like i can't believe they made
this decision uh we gotta break up these
companies
it's it's all meaningless it's a big
meaningless waste of our time
yeah what's the gop gonna do at the
national level they don't hold power
when they did held power they didn't do
any do much about it
i will say the trump administration was
on the verge of doing something about it
in the final year but the final year was
too late
they should have acted uh 2017 2018 when
people started getting banned from these
these platforms uh the only hope on a
political level now is that uh at the
state level
and you know texas has an interesting
bill florida has a
could be worse bill i guess uh but
better than nothing
it's better than nothing it does impose
some transparency requirements on the
tech companies which unlike the rest of
the bill can actually be enforced
uh but the texas bill actually is very
interesting and uh senate bill 12 in
texas that's worth taking a look at
so what is that going to do so unlike
the the florida bill the texas bill has
a general provision against viewpoint
based censorship
that doesn't mention the word common
carry or public accommodation
which are the two laws you can use to
regulate businesses and you know
restrict who they can and cannot deny
service to
uh but it functions in much the same way
and the reason why that's important is
because
unless there are only like uh a few
legal routes and you know i'll professor
by saying i'm a lawyer but there's only
a few legal routes you can go
to set to tell a business who they can
and cannot deny service to
or whose speech they can and cannot host
because otherwise they'll just say well
we're businesses businesses are
considered persons by uh by u.s law
therefore we have first amendment rights
to
to host the viewpoint we wanted to
censor the viewpoints we want
but there are certain types of
businesses that can't do that
uh common carriers have to provide
access to everyone on a
reasonable non-discriminatory basis uh
public accommodations have to do the
same under civil rights law there are
also state laws like california's unreal
law which is very wide-ranging and has
actually been used
uh in in viewpoint discrimination cases
successfully to say no
businesses can't exclude people like
even small businesses kind of the
unrollers
the unreal law that's a california law
right i remember talking about that but
can you break it down for us
uh so it's like a wide arranging uh
version of like the civil rights law you
can't discriminate based on like a wide
range of categories
and courts in california have
interpreted that to extend to viewpoint
so um really businesses that try to
exclude like political extremists
from uh their their uh their property uh
have been shot down in the courts the
courts have said you can't do that
uh under the california constitution as
well uh there was a very famous case in
the 1980s and this is an honorable
this is their constitution but there was
a famous case in the 80s
uh called pruniard v robins and that was
a shopping mall
uh that was taken to court because it
didn't allow political activism
uh on their property and the court said
well under california law under the
california constitution shopping malls
have to allow political activism
on their property so if california can
do all those things there's no reason
why
texas can't do it florida can't do it
any red state can't do it to the tech
companies
can you just sue based on california law
then to get your account reinstated or
what
well this is the thing uh you know this
has been tried before
the problem that all these state laws
will run into is
the well first of all that didn't apply
to tech companies you'd have to write it
and specifically apply to tech companies
uh the other problem of course is
section 230 of the communications
decency act
uh which is the law that says tech
companies can censor a wide range of
content
that they're not liable for user speech
and that only applies to tech companies
it doesn't apply to shopping malls
man talk about one of the stupidest
things
you know i i can't blame i can't blame
uh
the government the the publishers at the
time necessarily because they had no
idea what they were dealing with
and and to a certain degree it made
sense but a lot of people don't realize
i hear this all the time when people are
like they're they're a publisher now
they're a publisher it's like no that's
not what the law means not how it works
like the new york times you can't sue
them for the comments but there are a
bunch of really
important points to be made like when
twitter publishes those little blurbs
and news
things yeah that is twitter speech
that's twitter making a statement
everyone's a publisher
if you have a website even twitter but
it doesn't
it's it's actionable when twitter says
something not when one of their users
says something
uh yeah well what blows my mind i've
said this before is that wikipedia
enjoys the protection of section 230 i
mean that
makes no sense to me wikipedia says it's
an interactive computer service just
like facebook and twitter and you know
it provides a forum for all these
anonymous editors to make these articles
but the function of wikipedia is clearly
a traditional publisher it brands itself
as an encyclopedia
and it says on every article from
wikipedia not from you know
joe bob jr precisely and you know if the
encyclopedia britannica published now
in its paper encyclopedia far less
influential to wikipedia these days if
they defamed someone they'd be held
liable for that
but wikipedia defames people all the
time it's the entire purpose of some of
these articles about conservative
figures
and yet conservatives can't sue them
over that why can't you
mess anyone tried uh people have tried
yes in various uh jurisdictions but uh
have they ever made that argument that
wikipedia is not
look it's it's it's we've talked about
this before we had larry sanger who was
one of the co-founders
and we talked about how on twitter it
says you know at
libertarian blue it's you it's your
account your words wikipedia says from
wikipedia
if you want to see what the users posted
you got to go to the you got to go to
the uh
the um what's it called the history you
got it you got history yeah
view the history of the article and then
you can see post made by this person
the article itself is not is an article
published by wikipedia period
uh yeah but somehow section 230 protects
and it just shows how broken the law is
that it's protecting
the most one of the most powerful
publishers out there the site that's at
the top of nearly every
google search that can almost anyone
maybe the issue is
people haven't sued properly and the
argument needs to be
show the judge a picture of the article
where it says from wikipedia and say
so long as we keep here wikipedia
purports that the words on this page
that show no reference to any users or
any uh individuals
it says all of this is from wikipedia
then wikipedia has asserted
it is published this of its own volition
i mean i i would like to see people try
i'm not a lawyer but i
i assume like the amount of people that
wikipedia has defamed
i'm amazed that uh if there was a
possibility even the slightest
possibility you could win a defamation
case against them i'm sure someone would
have tried it by now
but i could be wrong i hope to be proven
wrong on that point i guess the issue is
damages
yeah you know for uh proving damages is
always particularly hard
but the main issue is that you need
millions of dollars to do it
i've heard so many stories from
prominent conservatives where they've
been defamed
a million a million one ways and it's
like well i don't have any money so i
can't sue them
that's all that's it massive
corporations can get away with it
individuals can't really do much about
it that's why social media was so
powerful because it finally gave the
individuals a chance to speak up and
push
back well now that's being threatened if
you got the wrong opinions
you're gone yeah if the uh the momentum
of the alternative media and independent
journalism that existed in 2015 and 2016
had been allowed to continue who didn't
have the rise of censorship
would have totally eclipsed cnn in the
new york times and watched washington
post that's why they had to kill it
kill uh kill you know uh online freedom
right in your speech
i think people need to realize i need
you i think people need to stop
and take a look at some web archives
look at what the internet was
15 years ago compared to what it is now
look at youtube
10 years ago compared to what it is now
and you're going to go wow
i did not realize how much it changed
before google bought youtube
no no no no i mean yes but i'm just
saying say anything but
it was pretty close i'm just saying the
internet in general
has become disney you know what i mean
like
back in the day the internet was nuts
disney's become crazy
the iron lore of oligarchy eventually
eventually ruling elites
inevitably emerged from any uh any
system yeah
well the issue i suppose is
it's a tendency within any system i
suppose
for uh organization
right so you look at movies we used to
make crazy movies a lot of them would
flop some would succeed he ended up with
weird things like groundhog day
amazing movie i don't think it made
blockbuster money
what happens is over time people start
realizing you know makes money giant
robots
blowing up buildings and you know cars
exploding so you get a bunch of
transformers movies with very little
story if that if any
because it transcends culture so big
explosions can be sold all over the
world
but american culture with with you know
english-speaking speakers is harder to
sell in foreign countries you gotta do a
bunch of work
so they're like just make it a bunch of
explosions little dialogue and then what
ends up ends up happening is we get all
movies that are just
derivative remakes bland yeah lowest
common denominator stuff
the fifth six seven spider-man remake
okay enough already
yeah yeah yeah and now we're at uh the
same place in the same same way in the
internet
you know for a long time people just
made whatever they want on the internet
it was a really weird place where people
did weird things
and then big companies started to
realize what really made money they
started to invest in only certain things
then big companies didn't like the idea
of french weirdos started banning them
and now look at the kind of shows that
are available to you
on on youtube what man people people
you really need to think about this only
a few years ago you could go on youtube
and search for the most ridiculous thing
like you know dmt for instance now you
do and it's all like cnn cbs nbc
it's all just big mainstream
corporations it's like turn on tv
yeah we leaked the uh we leaked the
youtube blacklist on this at breitbart
back in 2018
they have a literal list at youtube that
they call the controversial query
blacklist
and it's just a bunch of political terms
and whenever they add a term to that
blacklist
has thousands of entries by the way
whenever they add a term
it just reorders the search results so
cnn bbc and you know whatever
everything else you'd expect i love i
was searching for um
project veritas recently because you
know they uh put out that music video oh
yeah oligarchy
yeah so i'm looking at project veritas
and i type in you know project and i can
see all the suggested
posts like youtube's like you know it
gives you suggestions as to what it
thinks you're trying to type
and then as soon as i typed in ver it
just disappeared
all the suggestions were gone and then
it's like oh they figured out where i'm
going
and they don't like it they're not going
to autofill it for me how ridiculous is
that hoping that
i just search for project ver and then
get some random channel
maybe it's a good idea to create a
channel called project very for sure
and then just like you know talk about
project veritas
and that's it yeah then youtube will
autofill project very
project verit project vera dot verite
as project barrett dot has no no just
project verit
so that when people are searching for it
at auto fills and then people will click
your channel instead
veritus with a u well no that wouldn't i
guess i suppose it would autofill that
in 2008
um i was really politically active on
youtube just like screaming at the
at the internet to that we have the
control now now that we have internet
video the president of the united states
president of russia can do a video chat
and everyone can watch you don't need
secret service we're new in a new
paradigm
and i was talking and people were like
lighting up believing it and so cnn
wanted to get in on it
so they funded the cnn youtube debates
and for the first time in history they
took youtubers questions for the
the candidates and it was the most i
asked like about the federal reserve i
want to know why the banking
establishment had co-opted our
government
no no no what they they had the most
cookie-cutter stuff but they were like
look how we're
part of this is cnn look how we're part
of this new uprising this new
and then it took about two or three
years by 2011 they'd completely co-opted
the
political conversation google they don't
do anything like that anymore
no no and then they don't even do it
anymore they realize now they just
banned the comments on the white house
videos and
now they're youtube's eliminating thumbs
down for joe biden because nobody likes
the guy
oh yeah they they love internet freedom
and social media when uh
when it was helping elect obama and
helping do coups in the middle east
but as soon as 2016 comes along and get
resident trump everything changes
you go back to 2012 you will see
articles in the wake of the obama
reelection like
facebook and the power of friendship and
you know its impact on the 2012
election so they they loved it for a
while i think
i think shows like this and i mentioned
this before it's it is functions as a
pressure release valve
for a lot of people who are frustrated
you know right now there's a lot of
people who are listening hearing us talk
about censorship and it's making them
feel good that their concerns are being
addressed
but youtube and facebook and twitter
knows that this conversation likely
won't result in anything meaningful
the republicans right now in response to
the trump announcement
are saying stupid things like it's time
to break up these big tech monopolies
and it's like
what no 20th century what are you
talking about facebook
the reason facebook works is because
everyone uses it you can't break
facebook into 10 different facebooks
then what all of a sudden
ian and i aren't on the same network
anymore and so how does it work
i suppose if they break them up and
force them to go open source and like
decentralize but that would destroy the
company outright
so it's not something that can be done
what needs to happen is regulation on
the platform that allows speech
however what's happening is there are
some people that youtube
allows and why is it that i see every
day a youtube channel get nuked for the
stupidest reason
or no reason at all but we're allowed to
keep doing the show why
like i said i think it's a pressure
release valve if they got rid of every
single
you know channel then you'd end up with
a whole bunch of people
losing it outright feeling like they've
been just booted out they have nothing
left
and they go nuts but they need good old
you know milk toast tim cast irl so that
people are like tuning in and hearing
this and going
yeah yeah it's good it's good to get the
truth and it is
but they also know that it's just enough
to keep people calm correct and you know
if you go
if you step out of line even a little
bit they'll uh they'll just ban you
so you know there are some things
everyone knows they can't say they
banned desantis
youtube band desantis because he yelled
a uh a covert 19 round table with some
of the signs of the great barrington
declaration they outright banned him
uh i think it was a temporary suspension
i believe but you know there's a
governor of britain just you know
who will probably run for president in
2024. yeah well look you know
i said on twitter i think trump
shouldn't run because he's it's he's too
hot
as soon as as soon as trump pops his
head up every single
uninitiated liberal is going to be like
screaming and banging their head on the
wall just freaking out
and if you have someone like desantis
they'll still smear him they'll try
but desantis will not invoke the same
kind of anger that people had when it
was trump
well however i'll just say i i don't
think a republican can win you know a
lot of people are like maybe the
republicans can win in 2022 and even
asking it to the other day because
libs have gone to sleep i'm not
confident because what's gonna happen is
a conservative from 10 years ago will
never win
an election for a few reasons one the
modern republican party is more about
trump and populism than it was about
establishment conservatism
but more importantly if you even say
half the things that the democrats said
they'll call you far right and they'll
suspend you or shadow ban you
so what's going to happen is a
republican might win in 2024
but this republican is going to be
basically bernie sanders and then
the democrats going to be you know
further left the full-blown communists
maybe not by 2024 but certainly in the
next you know 15 or 20 years
when all of our opinions are being
filtered through the far left lens of
silicon valley
conservatives get banned and the
remaining conservatives
are the milk toast centrist
conservatives and then 10 years after
that
those people are fringe far right or
banned and the conservatives
are going to be socialist other kin or
something
i mean when we're talking about you know
a lot of people say you know the 2020
election was stolen
but in a sense it was but it was done in
the open by silicon valley censorship
which they didn't even
they didn't even try to hide the
censorship i mean we breitbart news
found out that google was censoring us
through google's
own analytics tools so they didn't they
didn't care how did that happen what do
they say
uh so they introduced a major algorithm
change around six months before the
election
and right after that algorithm change uh
impressions and clicks on uh
no breitbart's visibility on uh on
google search for breitbart newslinks it
went straight of a cliff like went right
down so it was clearly something
artificial haven't do a bunch of other
conservative sites as well and that
remained the case for uh
right until the election plus you could
search for
the exact string of breitbart news
headlines in google and the link
wouldn't come up
right same thing was happening to my
other channels as well and it wasn't
until i talked about it on this show
that one day people are like oh no your
channels are back
you would take the exact title of my
videos and put it in google and it
wouldn't come up
so something happened around i think it
was like may of 2018
where is that was that when you noticed
the algorithm shift uh it was a little
bit later than i would say it was may of
uh
2020. 2020. yeah so around six months
before the election
in may of 2018 there was
tons of people were talking about it you
could look in your analytics and check
your recommendations and you'd see just
one day it went boom to like
one it went from like 10 to like one
percent and then
people weren't getting any suggestions
anymore for any
political content that was deemed to be
you know
just anti-democrat anti-woke
and it's it's it's remarkable because
back then i said republicans were too
stupid to deal with it
that's still true today three years
later
they are still not smart enough to save
their own careers
and what's going to happen is by the
time any modern
young center right conservative type
gets into office
then the system will be it'll be too
late and you're not going to be able to
get elected because
the conservative the republicans at that
point are going to be socialists
well i i think um i'm a little bit more
optimistic because i think
um the the internet freedom that existed
before 2016
that that red kills a lot of people and
you know those people have not forgotten
they're still out there millions of
people
um and i think what what people need to
do is focus less on national elections
and more on activism at the local level
at the precinct level
you know influencing their local
republican party or the local democrat
party because that's where you can start
change you know from the bottom up
it's much less competitive they don't
need thousands of birds you need
hundreds or dozens
and just at the state level get some at
this at the priests at the precinct
level you go from the precinct level
to the uh the county level to the state
senate level
to the state level then why don't we
just have like uh why don't we start
with like a small town
implementing these these common carrier
rules uh well no with common carry rules
you need the state but to influence the
state you need to get involved with the
precinct level yeah so uh for example uh
one of the bad things
i like the texas uh tech bill but one of
the bad things texas did recently the
texas republican party
rather was uh issue a motion
uh taking the party off gab right yeah
because of
concerns about uh anti-semitic hate
speech or whatever and
governor abbott supported that that was
uh
it's kind of weird that you know the
texas republicans are saying oh we're
going to support free speech with this
bill which hasn't passed yet
but we're also going to leave the only
you know free speech social network
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time